[Music]
the first welcoming remarks will be by
our our Dean burst now many of you know
as a well known solid-state physicist
and we're very pleased that he will be
our welcoming addressees Bobby one
it's obviously really a special pleasure
for me be able to open these proceedings
among other things that gave me an
opportunity with Fred Epling and art
Kerman yesterday just to review the
history of LNS it's a credible series of
creative ventures in fact that if
nothing else that creativity is
demonstrated by having a 46th
anniversary which i think is the first
time in history at MIT we've had a 42nd
anniversary as all of you know or
probably know actually L&S was first
officially announced technically not in
1946 but actually on December 19th in
1945 by Karl Compton who was M president
of MIT and then was established formally
in 46 by by the Office of Naval Research
so in looking over the scientific
history of L&S this of course always a
very dangerous thing to do because
everybody in the audience who's made
great contributions has their ears
perked up but nevertheless I'll go
through a list of a few of really
singular accomplishments first of all as
probably many of you know L&S was the
birthplace of space astronomy through
the work of Bruno Rossi and her bridge
and number of others secondly one of the
first great Vanda graphs was established
here what used to be building 58 which
now actually doesn't exist anymore which
produced basically a myriad of important
data nuclear spectroscopy third of
course everybody knows the seminal work
done by Vicki and Herman on the optical
model in the compound nucleus played a
fundamental role in the development of
nuclear physics the discovery of
positronium by Martin Deutsch in 1951
worked by Steve Weinberg and CTP on the
unification of weak in electromagnetic
interactions approximately copper with
that in time these magnificent
experiments by Jerry Friedman and Henry
Kendall and a Keller out at SLAC on deep
inelastic scattering J psi by Sam King
more recently the development of the
inflationary universe model by
goof which of course has gotten
extraordinary and very exciting support
by the most recent Cobie results we're
also you probably know that the head of
the scientific program for Kobe is in
fact an MIT person ray Weiss and so MIT
is again intimately involved in naming
these I've been left out really a
countless number of other very important
contributions which may be kin or 20
years from now we will say one of them
will turn out to be the most singular
contribution it's the wonderful thing
about Sciences you never know at any
given time what's going to turn out to
have been the truly most important
contribution all of this was possible
because the laboratory has profited from
outstanding leadership first of all the
first head of LMS with Zacharias who
played a role in founding the laboratory
he was then followed by Peter Dimas who
oversaw the lab over a very long period
of extraordinary productivity
productivity followed by Martin Dwight
Francis Lowe Jerry Friedman and most
recently Arthur Kerman trooper who truly
distinguished scientists all of them and
also outstanding administrators in
addition there were year-long or
thereabout fill-ins by Bernie Feld Dave
Frisch and of course we're all very
sorry is not with us for the celebration
in Vicki I also have to mention that the
lab everybody who interacts with the lab
knows that although all of these people
are outstanding scientists and
administrators actually the real reason
the lab functions at all is Fred Epling
who has guided the laboratory partly
scientifically and completely
administrative Lee for close to 40 years
and I think we all owe a very special
debt to Fred
now of course even at MIT laboratories
don't function unless they're funded and
we've been extraordinarily fortunate to
have continued funding of the laboratory
for nuclear science in the form of a
contract for 46 years first by onr that
was between 46 and 58 and since that
time by it's actually always been the
same laboratory same agency but its name
has changed continuously it was first
AEC then Oda and now Department of
Energy and of course also indebted to
the federal government for its loyalty
and supportive L&S of course this
continuing support wouldn't have been
possible we're not for the stellar
contributions which have already some of
which I've already reviewed so the
program to me looks really outstanding
I'm really looking forward myself to
hearing many of these talks and I sure
you all will enjoy the program as well
as much as I well and I welcome you
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you Bob
Arthur Kerman will make this who's the
director of the laboratory will make the
next remarks
little safe time with these remarks
because I'm not going to go for very
long I would like to thank the
organizers of this affair and also our
staff who worked really very hard Ivo
way beyond the call of duty to make this
fair a success which I think is going to
be I'd like to make just a comment
y46 which was already mentioned I've
been being asked that too the last six
months almost anybody who talks to me
asks why 46 and we have a lot of excuses
like 46 is half of 92 46 is the year
when we were founded somebody said
something yesterday which is really true
MIT is always a maverick we have to do
things differently and then there was a
really great remark this is a fundraiser
for the hundredth gonna take us that
long to raise the funds but I think the
best what I've heard is that anytime is
a good time to throw a party and that's
what we're doing
and we hope everyone enjoys it let's be
on with the festivities
[Applause]
let us indeed be on with the festivities
it's a Peter Peter Dimas is the
chairperson of the first session
good morning Arthur has provided a basis
for an aside a I to speculated on why 46
and I looked at the periodic table there
are two stable 46 isotopes they're rare
one is titanium and the other is calcium
calcium is crusty and titanium stuff
perhaps it describes the laboratory the
it really boggles the mind to think of
all the things that have been done not
just the quantity but the quality and
for those of us who run it at someone or
normal pace it's been awesome the order
of this morning is to hear of the early
days but before I get to that Mack
Hubbard one of the special people of
that period of the first period has
asked me to give his greetings to his
friends here and for those who may not
know Mack he was Gerald Zechariah's very
resourceful right arm he set up the
laboratories original technical and
administrative facilities and he left
quite quite a challenge father to live
up to I'm pleased to say that I've met
and talked with Malcolm a number of
times in this past year he's as sharp as
ever
he's a treasure-house of recollections
and it is a shame that he can't be part
of this activity